اهلا بكم الى عدد جديد من مراسلون برنامج
الذي يعنى بتقارير مراسلينا عبر العالم
مشاهدينا في عدد اليوم نرحل بكم الى
اوكرانيا العديد من المسلمين الاوكرانيين
يشاركون في جهود الدفاع عن اوكرانيا منذ
بدايه الحرب وغزوها من قبل روسيا حيث تشهد
البلاد حضورا لافتا للمسلمين من القوقاز
في القتال ضد الجيش الروسي ولعل ابرز
المقاتلين واهمهم هم المقاتلون الشيشان
وهذا منذ اعترافه البرلمان الاوكراني
باستقلال جمهوريه اشكيريا الشيشانيه
واعلانها اراض محتله من قبل موسكو
مشاهدينا قبل مشاهده الموضوع معنا في
الاستوديو زميلنا رائد ابو زيد الذي شارك
في اعداد وتصوير موضح حلقه اليوم والعائد
من اوكرانيا اهلا وسهلا بك رائد رائد قبل
متابعه
الموضوع اريد ان اسالك عن تفصيل مهم بشان
الذين يشاركون في هذه الحرب الكثير منهم
يعتبرونها جهاد بين هلالين او يصفونها
بانها حرب مقدسه جهاد رغم ان الاغلبيه في
اوكرانيا
هم مسيحيون نعم المصطلح او الهويه الدينيه
او هذا المصطلح تم استخدامه في هذه الحرب
بدايه في بدايه هذه الحرب في مايو بول من
قبل
الشيشان المقاتلين مع روسيا من الجهه
الاوكرانيه الذين يقاتلون مع الجيش
الاوكراني اليوم وهم الكثير من
الاوكرانيين المسلمين سواء كانوا يقاتلون
كجنود في الجيش الاوكراني او خلال مع
الشيشان في الويه وكتائب مختلفه تحدثنا
الى المفتي الذي قال انا لم ادعو الى
الجهاد بالرغم انني ان متاكد ان ما نقوم
به هو الجهاز لذلك لاننا ندافع عن ارضنا
ندافع عن بيوتنا وما دعوته اليوم دون ان
استخدم مص طلح الجهاد لان اوكرانيا بلد
علماني وليس هناك للمفتي دور قضاي او
دستوريه يسمح له الدعوه الى الجهه اذا
نعيد ابقاء معنا مشاهدينا ندعوكم الى
متابعه موضوع حلقه اليوم المراسلون ونعود
اليكم بالمزيد مع
[موسيقى]
سياره الاسعاف تعود من الجبهه على متنها
جندي مصاب بالرصاصه في المعده
كيف حالك بخير اصبر بقيت 10 دقائق فقط
ونصف غير سعيد اسماعيلوف مهنته في الحرب
هو اليوم ممرض متطوع في الجيش الاوكراني
منذ الاول من ديسمبر ننقل يوميا الجرحى
الان بدات حرب الشوارع وهنالك جنود مصابون
بجروح سببها الطلقات الناريه
لا يسمح لنا الجيش بالذهاب الى المستشفى
فعنوانه يجب ان يبقى سرا
يعطينا سعيد موعدا في مكان اخر في كستانت
نيفكا في المسجد
هرب الكثير من سكان البلده تاركين المكان
للمقاتلين
على بعد 26 كيلومترا من الجبهه ذوي
الانفجارات لا يتوقف سعيد مفتن سابق اليوم
يئم بالمصلين في صلاه الجمعه بملابسه
العسكريه قاتل يعذبهم
الله
[موسيقى]
يشفي ويبوب الله على من يشاء
في ايام الحرب للخطبه صدى مختلف تروى فيها
قصص من الدين عن القتال وعن الدفاع عن
الوطن
انا متاكد تماما من ان هذا هو الجهاد لانه
وفقا لحكم الشريعه يسمح لنا بحمايه حياتنا
وممتلكاتنا واطفالنا وعائلاتنا
دعوت للدفاع عن الوطن لم استخدم مصطلح
الجهاد لان اوكرانيا دوله علمانيه
غالبيه السكان في اوكرانيا مسيحيون ويبلغ
عدد المسلمين فيها اكثر من نصف مليون نسمه
اي واحدا في المئه من اجمالي عدد السكان
دفع الغزو الروسي الكثير منهم للتطوع
والمساعده كمحمد علي من مدينه خاركيف
في السابع والعشرين من فبراير اقتحمت
مجموعه صغيره من الروس المدينه
ودارت معاركنا
في ذلك اليوم راى هذه المدرسه في مدينته
تحتر نمبر راينا كل شيء باعيننا
كانت المدرسه لا تزال تحترق كيف وكنا نشم
رائحه الجثث المحترقه
لا يمكن مقارنه ذلك مع اي شيء اخر
قرر حينها الالتحاق بمجموعه من المسلمين
تساعد السكان في خاركيف
الطعام جاهز هيا ناكل
نلتقي بالحج موعد ممثل المسلمين في خاركيف
وامام متطوع في الجيش
كما ترون خيره الناس في بلدنا يموتون
الشباب يذهبون الى الحرب ويموتون لقد دفنا
بالفعل الكثير من رجالنا واحيانا من دون
معرفه هويه الضحيه هل يمكننا ان نغفر ذلك
بالتاكيد لا هذا نشاط جديد على المسلمين
في اوكرانيا الذين لم يكونوا فاعلين في
السابقوش في الماضي تحت تاثير الدعايه
السياسيه والاعلاميه الروسيه كان يتم
التعامل مع المسلمين كارهابيين
[موسيقى]
المجتمع وتغيرت نظرته ليقبلنا كما نحن
وهذه اشاره لنا لنصبح ناشطين في المجتمع
ونعمل ما بوسعنا لوطننا
للثقافه الاسلاميه الكل يريد ان يلعب دورا
فعالا في المساعده السلام عليكم
تكرسون تاليا ساعات بعد عملها لصنع الشموع
شموع للخنادق
هذه الشموع لمساعدتهم على التدفئه وعلى
تسخين الطعام وكذلك لجعلهم يشعرون بنوع من
الراحه او على الاقل
ليشعروا باننا نتذكرهم نريد المساعده لان
قضيهنا مشتركه
تعلمت نتاليا طريقه ملء هذه العلب
بالبرافين من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وهذا يمنحها بعض الامل
بماذا اشعر طبعا قلبي راد وانا سعيده
لانني اقوم بهذا العمل البسيط
انا فخوره لانني استطيع القيام بذلك
واقول الحمد لله الحمد لله شموعنا تاليا
ينقلها محمد علي والحاج مراد في اليوم
التالي يحملان السياره بالمعدات والمواد
الغذائيه كلها تذهب للمقاتلين في باقود
والله قبل
خذهم الطريق عبر المناطق المحرره من الجيش
الروسي
في هذه الحرب كل شيء يمكن ان يتغير في ايه
لحظه لهذا السبب لدينا الان هذه الخطه
ولكن الله وحده يعلم ما سيحدث
نقترب من بخموت تصبح الرحله اكثر خطوره
التوتر سيد الموقف
هذا الطريق الترابي فقط ينقلنا الى قلب
المدينه عندما مدخلها تصطدم سيارتنا بكتله
خرسانيه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
السياره الى جانب الطريق مع كحبل
جرها اكثر واقرب
نحن محاطون بمواقع المدفعيه القصف كثيف
يجب اخراج الصحفيين من هنا لا يمكنهما
البقاء هنا
يقرر الحجم مواد ترك السياره والركوب مع
جنود من الكتيبه الشيشانيه المكان خطير
يجب مغادرته سريعا هيا هيا هيا
ندخل بخموت اصبحت مدينه اشباح
فارغه وشوارعها ضحيه القصف الروسي المتكرر
القذائف ليست بعيده من هنا
ننزل لقبو المبنى يحب الامام سماع اخر
اخبار الجبهه
علمنا بالامس ان الروسي قد اقتربوا من
بخموت
لكن اخواننا اخبرونا انهم تمكنوا من صدهم
الدفاع والمقاومه اخبار تشعرني بالفرح
زيارته ثمينه للجنود ويقضي وقتا قيما معهم
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
نسعد لرؤيته فمعا سننتصر الوضع تحت سيطره
وموقعنا مستقره ومحميه
يقاتل الشيشانيون الى جانب الاوكرانيين
عدوهم المشترك روسيا مسلم شبر لويبسكي هو
قائد كتيبه الشيخ منصور الشيشاني يقاتل في
الدومباس منذ عام 2015
لقد فرض علينا الروس هذه الحرب ولهذا
السبب علينا القتال والبقاء على قيد
الحياه باستخدام اي ادوات ممكنه
تكتيكنا الرئيسي هو حرب العصابات لاننا لا
نملك ما يكفي من العتاد لمعارك متكافئه
فليست لدينا طائرات ولا دبابات ولا مدفعيه
ولا منظومه صواريخ متطوره
حان وقت الرحيل نور الدين يتفقد اسطح
المباني خوفا من القناصين
بدا يقاتل الروس في حرب الشيشان الثانيه
كان عمره 14 عاما
لم اسامح ما فعله الروس في بلدي ولن اسامح
ابدا
ساحارب هذا النظام حتى الموت حتى يتم
تدميره
الان اعتقد ان اوروبا والعالم كله قد
فهموا من هم الارهابيون
من الدومباس الى العاصمه كييف
ماجا وجه اخر لهذه الحرب درس في فرنسا
والتحق بصفوف كتيبه جوهر دودي كتيبه
شيشانيه اخرى تدافع عنك
ما ترونه هناك المدفع الرشاش الثقيل هو
رشاش روسي غنمناه في ايزيون كان هناك
العديد من الدبابات التي تخلى عنها الجيش
الروسي
لكنه يفضل عدم الكشف عن هويته
يبدو ان اوكرانيا مستعده للمضي قدما اوكي
لذا سنساعدها وسنظل بجانبها حتى النصر
انظروا هنا انه رمز التتار الاوكرانيين
والشيشان
انه للدفاع عن اوكرانيا معا ضد الارهاب
الاحمر
التتار اكبر جاليه مسلمه في اوكرانيا وهم
سكان شبه جزيره القرم الاصليون مسلمون منذ
القرن الرابع عشر هم ايضا اضطهدهم بوتين
كل هذه الكتب من مكتبات الاراضي المحتله
نجمعها بسبب تدمير الكثير من المكتبات
وحرق الكثير منها
ابناء بومدير المعهد الاوكراني للثقافه
تتاري يحاول الحفاظ على هويه شعبه منذ
انضمت روسيا شبه جزيره القرم
في بدايه عام 2014 حاولت روسيا منحنى بعض
المزايا الماليه وما الى ذلك لكن جميع
اتاري القرن تقريبا قالوا لا لدينا وطن
واحد هو اوكرانيا وارضنا هي شبه جزيره
القرم اذا حاولنا التضحيه بالقرم وتقديم
شبه الجزيره لروسيا فهذا يعني ان هذه
الحرب ستكون حرب اجيالنا القادمه
اليوم عليم يدفنون احد جنود كتيبه القرم
الله اكبر
كان من اهم الاسماء في مجتمع التاتا قتل
في بخموت تودعه في هذه الظروف مفجع لاهله
واصدقائه
في هذه الحرب مات واحد اخر من تتار القرن
مسلم اوكراني شجاع
كان يكافح من اجل الوطن
اعلان موت رفيق السلاح مهمه صعبه تكلف بها
قائد الكتيبه عيسى اكيف من الصعب علي جدا
التعبير عن كل هذا بالكلمات بالنسبه
لمعظمنا فقد كان مثل الاخ كان شخصا مقربا
جدا ولا يمكنني حتى نطق الكلمه الصحيحه
من الصعب جدا علينا وسننتقم له بالتاكيد
ارض الوطن تحتضن من مات لاجلها مسلما كان
او مسيحيا بالنسبه للاوكرانيين دمائهم هي
الثمن لكن كل قبر يحفر يذكرهم بان العوده
الى الوراء
اصبحت مستحيله
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في مراسلون
الرائد ابو زيده لازال معي للمزيد حول
الموضوع راي تبعنا الموضوع وشهدنا الكتائب
الشيشانيه المسلمه قوميه اخرى تقاتل من
اجل اوكرانيا ما هي دوافعهم نعم للشيشان
للشيشان دوافع عده بدايه هم يردون الجميل
للاوكرانيين الذين قتلوا معهم في حرب
الشيشان الاولى والثانيه بصوره المقاتل
المعروف عند الشيشان او الكسندر وموزاييكو
الذي كان يطلق عليه بالاخ المسيحي وكان
يقاتل في حرب الشيشان اولا ثانيا في
الثامن عشر من اكتوبر 2022 قام البرلمان
الاوكراني بالاعتراض بجمهوريه اشكيريا
واعتبارها اراضي شيشانيه محتله من قبل
روسيا والهدف الثالث هذا ما رايناه في
كتيبه الشيخ منصور التي كنا معهم في بخموت
او في كتيبه جوهره دايب في محيط مدينه كيب
ان لهم عدوا
مشتركين وهو روسيا طيب هناك قوميه اخرى
ايضا رائد تشارك قوميه وتدين بالاسلام
كدين وتشارك ايضا الى جانب الاوكرانيين ضد
روسيا هم التاتار لماذا يقاتلون الى جانب
كييف لهم قصه حزينه مع روسيا حيث قام
الاتحاد السوفيتي في عام 1944 بنقلهم
عائلات عاده بعد عام 1991 هم يرون في ان
اوكرانيا ارضهم رساله ولكن هناك منذ
سبتمبر 2022 هناك رسائل موجهه
بتنتج شبه جزيره القرم وهذه الرساله
وجهتها تميلات الشيبا الممثله الدائمه
للرئيس الاوكراني تحدثنا اليها ولنستمع
بامكانكم البقاء في شبه جزيره القرم
ابقوا فيها
سن التجنيد الاجباري في الجيش الروسي
فللاسف
اهرب
ولكن لا تنخرط في الجيش الروسي
ضد بلدكم وضد شعبكم
رائد ابو زيدان حلقه اليوم شكرا جزيلا لك
على الموضوع المهم هذا المسلمون الذين
يقاتلون في اوكرانيا الى جانب اوكرانيا ضد
روسيا شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه
القاكم في حلقه جديده وتحقيق جديد من
مراسلون الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]